The conditions that the author mentions
for us
are three.
Number one
Number two is saying Bismillah.
And number three is
successive
performance of wudu.
Which means that you make it all
together.
You don't separate them too far apart.
So,
this is
a very unique take on the conditions of
wudu.
Most usually the scholars will the
majority of the scholars view the
conditions of wudu
to be more than this.
And
the pillars of wudu to be more.
But, we will follow the
author.
What's important for us to take from
this here
is
a niya.
Intention. And that's a condition in
every act of worship. Every act of
worship. 99% of all acts of worship are
predicated on intention.
However, there are some very few
acts of worship which will be considered
as acts of worship without intention by
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. But, wudu is
not one of them.
A narration I think most of us are
familiar with.
The prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
tells us
in a narration which is in all of the
six books of Hadith
on the authority of Omar,
he says
that deeds are judged and rewarded based
on intentions.
Right? So a person must have that
intention.
However, verbalizing that intention
is found nowhere in the Quran and
Sunnah.
To actually verbalize some kind of
intention,
nowhere is this found nor is it found in
the works of the four original Imams of
Fiqh.
The Imams of the four Madhahib, this was
postulated many years after the death of
the four Imams of the Madhhab. However,
the scholars, the Imams of Islam along
with the companions, all agree that
there is no instance in which a person
will verbalize his intention.
Because intention is something that does
not need to be verbalized
in order for it to be
valid or in order for it to be correct.
The author then mentions at-Tasmiyah.
And this is a point of contention
amongst the scholarship of Islam. Some
view that at-Tasmiyah, saying Bismillah,
is a condition of Wudu being
valid,
while others view that it is min
mukammilatil Wudu. It is something that
is ideal for the Wudu.
If we were to really look at the at the
evidence for this,
there is only one really clear narration
that mentions this in all of the Sunnah,
all of the authentic Sunnah.
[Arabic recitation]
that articulates as much.
And that is
[Arabic recitation]
Ibn Majah that the Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said,
that there is no valid salah
for a person who does not
have wudu.
And furthermore, there is no valid wudu
for a person who does not mention
Allah's name on the wudu.
Now, if the narration is authentic and
if it's clear,
then why exactly is it a point of
contention amongst the scholars?
Right? You would imagine that
if the narration is authentic
and if it's clear this,
you would imagine that they would all
agree to that. And that's correct
mostly. However, they don't all agree
that this narration is authentic.
Many view this narration as being weak.
But another reason is
that there are other instances in which
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam's
actions
actually contradict this narration.
So, for instance, just
one example of this, a companion
came upon the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam while he was making wudu
and he said assalam to him and the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
responded after he had finished wudu.
And he said,
He said, I I disliked
remembering or mentioning Allah's name
without wudu.
Right? So, part of that would be what?
Bismillah.
Correct?
So, this is what for instance in the
Hanafi madhhab they cite as a
contradiction to this narration.
However,
being that the narration is authentic
and being that the narration is pretty
clear in its instruction, a person is to
say Bismillah and the only time they are
exempted from saying Bismillah
is if they forget. If a person were to
make wudu and forgot to say Bismillah,
they say Bismillah at any point in the
wudu.
Right? Even if they're at the last part
of wudu, they say Bismillah.
If they forget completely until the wudu
is over, then the wudu in sha Allah is
valid. This is the
opinion of a Shafi and Ahmad
and it is most in line with the
narrations, the authentic narrations.
It's most comprehensive and inclusive.
So, a person says Bismillah ma al-dhikr.
When is
saying Bismillah obligatory? It's
obligatory when a person remembers. If a
person does not remember, it is not
obligatory for that person until he
remembers.